in New York City Police have arrested
another person in connection with
druggings and robberies that led to at
least two murders and in Northern
California the executive director of the
San Jose Police Officers Association is
accused of Distributing drugs all over
the country so we're going to actually
start with the West Coast story my
goodness 64 year old Joanne Segovia
appeared in a federal courtroom on
Friday after investigators charged her
with attempting to bring illegal
synthetic opioids into the country from
overseas the drug was a form of fentanyl
one of the leading causes of overdoses
in the United States prosecutors say
Segovia was involved in a National
Distribution scheme using both personal
and office computers to order the
illegal substances and initial police
interviews Segovia denied her
involvement and instead blamed it on her
housekeeper the San Jose Police Officers
Association said Thursday that they are
conducting their own internal
investigation into segovia's activity at
the organization she has been released
without bail under strict conditions
from the judge her neck hearing is set
for April 28th let me bring back in
Brian buckmeyer to talk about this so
Brian segovia's organization is against
everything that she is being charged
with what do you take away from the case
I take away that they're not watching
their own Segovia was bold enough and
was able to not just use her personal
computer but her work one as well to
order drugs internationally the San Jose
police may not have known what Segovia
was doing but to be able to use police
resources to further the fentanyl
epidemic in this country is disturbing
to say the least we're all told to look
at the southern border and this is how
it's coming in but no it seems to be
coming from this police force now I'm
curious as to why no bail was set this
seems a like a serious crime to me and
one that a judge would set some amount
of bail I'm worried that this could be a
foreshadowing of Segovia getting a
different type of justice that others
would have received okay well as I said
that's the West Coast now let's go to
the east coast where two men have been
arrested in connection with drugging
deaths in New York City 25 year old
Julio Ramirez was found dead in a taxi
last April after leaving an lgbtq bar
called The Ritz in Hell's Kitchen the
medical examiner described his death as
a quote drug facilitated theft
investigators found out that money that
found out money was taken from the
victim's Financial accounts using the
facial recognition technology on his
phone thirty-year-old Jacob barroso was
arrested and charged with Ramirez's
murder on Saturday and he's also charged
with a robbery grand larceny and
identity theft 33-year-old John umberger
also met a similar fate just weeks after
Ramirez's death he left the lgbtq club Q
in the same neighborhood and was found
dead five days later from the same drug
cocktail his financial accounts were
also stolen from and accessed through
his cell phone a second suspect Robert
demaio surrendered on Monday Jaquan
Hamilton was also indicted last week but
he hasn't been caught yet so let me
bring in Terry Austin's talk about this
kind of insane and Shilling case so
Terry multiple people they've been
charged do you think one of them could
end up becoming a cooperating witness
and all this you know what Jesse I think
there's a very good chance that one of
them will be a cooperating witness
anytime you have multiple arrests for
the same crime the police are going to
want to work with one of them to try to
get the others and one of the things
that they'll do is tell those witnesses
that look we have evidence against you
and so I believe that they're going to
do that so they can get everybody at the
end of the day the authorities want to
shut down this operation in order to do
that it's going to be important to get
one to testify against the others
and welcome back everybody we're moving
now to Miami Florida where trials
started on Monday for Miguel Ruiz Lobo
he's charged a connection to the brutal
death of an 11 year old girl Martha
Guzman was found dead in her home nine
years ago and prosecutors suspect that
Ruiz Lobo killed her as Revenge Guzman's
mother dated the defendant for several
years and broke up with him five months
before her daughter's death prosecutors
say Guzman convinced her mother to break
up with him after accusing him of being
emotionally abusive according to
investigators video surveillance shows
the moments that Ruiz Lobo enters and
leaves the victims home which he got
into with his own key once inside
prosecutors say he fatally stabbed the
victim slitting her wrists and throat
investigators say the victim had a
history of self-harm so the defendant
staged her death to look like a suicide
during opening statements Ruiz lobo's
defense attorney explained why this case
isn't so black and white
Miguel
when questioned was asked for example to
give a sample of DNA he could refuse
but he had no reason to and he willingly
great even when told he didn't have to
he agreed to speak to the police
even when told he didn't have to he
consented to a search of the apartment
in his room
he consented to the photographs being
taken that you saw and
he consented to a search of his car and
he told the police where the car was
located
what you will not hear
what you will not hear is that while
they went into the apartment to look for
evidence
they never looked at his car
the car that he
according to them drove away from the
murder scene
the car that
presumably if they had looked and if
they were right
would have traces of blood or other
evidence he blocked
Brian when you think about the forensics
in the case we're sure they're going to
be the most difficult for the defense
yes I see two that really stick out to
me Jesse one is the DNA under the
victim's fingernails from our
understanding it's the defendants and so
a lot of people you don't even need to
be an internet sleuth or big in a true
crime you think someone dies they try to
defend themselves check the fingernails
and if there's a match that's a hard uh
thing to come from underneath but also
sometimes it's not the crime but it's
the cover-up it's the attempt to try to
make this look like a suicide and a
slitting of the wrist my understanding
is that the wrists were slit so deep
that they almost fell off and so it
really shows that someone must have
known who this what this young girl was
to know that she suffered from self-harm
and try to fake it enough to the point
that they've almost mutilated her so it
shows anger and knowledge of her and who
else could that be but an ex-boyfriend
with DNA under her fingernails those two
facts are very damaging for the defense
yeah I think that's a really good point
in Terry the victim sister took the
stand to help to tell her story what
were some of the key takeaways from her
testimony well first of all Jesse she
was extremely credible now there is a
language barrier here so there was an
interpreter and you have to listen very
closely to what she says so that you can
hear what the interpretation is but she
got very emotional on that stand
particularly when she started talking
about her sister's young age of 11. the
two critical points I think one the fact
that the defendant told her he didn't
like Marta he did not like her sister
and so that was before the crime and I
think that that was very pivotal in the
case the other issue that video that we
saw of the defendant walking out she
identified him and I think on Cross they
should have said something but they
asked her no questions
what a case and you know it's just
another example of sorry the majority of
the cases we're covering right now are
just really horrifying deaths of
children but unfortunately the
perpetrators out there are just equally
a sinister
[Music]
foreign